mon Saif Bharti came out of retirement
to take up the job of UN Ambassador to
coincide with his country's two-year
term on the Security Council but now
he's been fired on the orders of the
country's president Kai Syed and the
reason is the issue of Palestine which
perhaps seems odd because it's one of
the country's main stated priorities as
ambassador Bharti himself made clear at
the beginning of the year kamisato
Kunal's
Tunisia will be the voice of the Arab
world in the African continent and will
push for the settlement of just causes
particularly the Palestinian cause when
the Trump plan for the Middle East was
made public just over a week ago the
Palestinian ambassador to the UN Riyad
Mansour told reporters that President
Mahmoud Abbas was be coming to New York
as ambassador Bharti stood by his side
he explained that Tunisia as the Arab
member of the Security Council would
draw up a resolution rejecting the Trump
plan I'm told ambassador Bharti was told
news of his firing
shortly before Jared Kushner held a
lunch with members of the Security
Council the Tunisians were represented
by their deputy ambassador other council
members including the current president
would taken by surprise by the news I
must say I was quite shocked to hear
that no I don't know all the details the
reasons behind this but he was a very
good colleague and I really very much
regrets to see him leaving so why has
this veteran diplomat been fired the
foreign ministry in Tunis says he has
been dismissed for purely professional
reasons concerning his weak performance
and lack of coordination with the
ministry on important matters under
discussion at the UN but that might not
be the whole story I've spoken to
diplomats from the number of Security
Council countries who've told me they've
heard that Jared Kushner himself called
Genesius president before the Ambassador
was dismissed one source says the
kushner call was to the prime minister
not the president
the
White House is not confirming there was
a call at all one US official says the
Tunisians told them that the Ambassador
was dismissed because he'd gone rogue
James BAE's al Jazeera at the United
Nations